this year's nominated documentaries took
us out of our everyday lives and gave us
a chance to walk in someone else's shoes
it wasn't always a comfortable walk but
it's a journey that we would have never
taken or traveled otherwise as a result
these films four of which are directed
are co-directed by women
[Applause]
have an impact not just for today but
will resonate for with us for years to
come here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature American Factory
Stephen boga Julia Riker and Jeff Riker
the cave fierce fired just being a
Barker and see goodbye Kevin the edge of
democracy Petra Costa Johanna not
Isidoro Shane Morris and thiago palma
for sama Waddell Khatib and Edward was
honey land
lubos de fauna tomorrow patiska an
autonomous yogya and the Oscar goes to
American Factory
[Applause]
this is the first
nomination for Steven
and fourth nomination with Julia
the first win
nomination for Jack right
[Applause]
Wow
thank you well even before that envelope
got opened just being in the presence in
the company of our sister and brother
documentarians who risked to risk their
lives making stories bringing stories to
us about hospitals being bombed in Syria
about Brazil about Macedonia we were so
proud we are inspired by you guys our
film is from Ohio and China go Buckeyes
and sorry and but it really could be
from anywhere that people put on a
uniform punch a clock trying to make
their families have a better life
working people have it harder and harder
these days and we believe that things
will get better
when workers of the world unite
thank you Academy thank you to everyone
who trusted us to tell your story
shechet chow - Wang thank you to our
unstoppable crew our beloved friends and
family each and John B Julie are
unstoppable editor Lindsay Utes and to
those big hearted people at Netflix
participant media higher ground
productions and the tough inventive
great people of Dayton Ohio
[Applause]